alpha de palettes fallait pas bouger
bouger et je peux bouger se lancer suis
caribou il faut pas bouger bien dernier
coup de tête à partir en belgique comme
ça un jour non c'était pas un pari non
plus et enfin bon ça fait bizarre quand
tu te fais une ville de moins loin en
belgique moins loin moins 300 morts de
tongs loin de tout souci les glaives in
dernier coup de coeur il ya 11 ans quand
même en jeu et de ma femme donc dernier
vrai coup de coeur rien on a des coups
de coeur pour tuer ce jour des gens sur
des chaussures des événements le vrai
dernier coup de coeur qui dure c'est
frédéric te dire toujours oui c'est fort
ça collait toujours aller dans les coups
de poing non écoute moi j'ai de faire un
jeu très vois un truc c'était à l'époque
où je faisais tu es les havrais toi tu
fais un jour j'étais arrivé avec la
gueule complètement déformée s'était
déchiré la tronche dans une bagarre et
où je t'avais dit je vais te fais
chauffer dans métro avec ma femme
et j'avais voulu défendre ma femme parce
que j'avais pas envie de dire la vérité
je peux te dire maintenant en fait
j'étais allé dans une soirée les potes
et ça avait terminé en baston générale
les bacs avait dit du mal de moi et tu
m'avais défendu mais c'est ça voilà
je vais tuer lâchement révélé vachement
de l'étoile n'est pas question
maintenant tu fais ce métier lui pas
question d'une bagarre dubawi voyons
donc j'avais pas aux hits avouer que je
vous dise tu voyais pas cru fatalité
serment de me croire ce que j'en dis ah
là j'arrive à la fiche 69
vous pouvez me poser la question que
vous voulez la question la question que
vous faites le choix de l'ancien géant
une question que tous les spectateurs se
pose me d'être choses qui peuvent se
poser quand on regarde combien tu as
zone us avec les années tu sais ça
change c'est dans télé 7 jours ça nous
amuse
non non et acheta vraiment vraiment
vraiment 52 non non a dit judith pose
une question et thierry 06 toujours
emmerdé
c'est la question que j'aimerais
demander vous avez une idée vous quittez
un quelqu'un peut me fils aîné d ascq et
m me aline us qui tiennent toujours les
nuits blanches
oui mais maintenant quand j'étais blessé
pour travailler c'est plus pour sortir
ce que tu te fout de notre gueule
dernier coup de foudre
abbas et le we dernier coup de foudre
bah tiens le scénario de la vérité de ce
conflit paix avant de recevoir vraiment
une suite enseigne on obligé on a un
devoir y est c'est fait même pas ce
qu'on lui doit tant et d'eau puis on la
termine on sait tous appelés vous la
trouvez vraiment à ma dernier coup de
gueule hier d'anjou qui chassait
choisissent ou ball et je gueule
beaucoup et coléreuse jetons et
poussèrent dans une radio
ils m'ont fait chier j'ai quitté le
plateau et en plus j'ai été entraînée
toute l'équipe jardy venait en ce
dernier coup de bluff
dernier coup de bluff c'est pour avoir
un rôle dans un film j'ai fait croire à
lambert wilson que j'étais engagé dans
le même film que lui
ouais parce que je n'arrivais pas
rencontrer la médiatrice brigitte rond
et priori ne voulait pas de moi et j'ai
je recroise ans même si je joue dans le
film dit moi aussi
aussi génial il appelle à riga crise et
qui m'a appelé après m'a dit maison ça
veut dire quoi
dans mon film j ben ça tient qu'à toile
ma rencontre et n'a donné voilà il a
appris le poker avec la vérité dernier
coup de barre en ce moment je suis
pourri tkc j'avais tout bas là ça sent
bon la barre
parce que c'est un mois et demi que tu
es donc en tournée que vers israël a pas
pu hélas pas eu l'occasion de venir à
une vis à vis pas la fan bruno solo elle
a une vie les sculpteurs l artiste
beaucoup de travail en soi en belgique
elle a pas eu le temps elle préfère me
rejoint demain à aux [ __ ] sûr c'est
que j'ai la banane poyo la cdc doit ni
cantonaux
bruno solo la vérité
hélas trop
pour un père quelques gmail d'abord